hey buster did you see that video yeah i
just watched it it was awful i can't
believe someone would be hurt like that
just because they're black racism is so
unfair no one should ever judge someone
by the color of their skin but how could
it happen here in elwood city right
outside the sugar bowl buster it happens
everywhere i was talking to mrs mcgrady
the other day she said there's a really
long history of black people not being
treated fairly in this country why does
it keep happening well for the same
reason that unicorns keep sitting on
your roof
that is it's not happening
like at all there have been
comparatively few unjustified police
shootings
of anyone and almost none of them
have any connection to racism
so this is not a thing that's actually
happening and yet yet the people behind
arthur
want small children to imagine they live
in a country where black people are
being killed left and right for the
color of their skin just like walking on
the street they're just getting murdered
by the cops